عدد قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدء
العمليه العسكريه على غزه بلغ حتى اللحظه
447 عسكريا الملفت للنظر ان من بين القتلى
119 ضابطا اما البقيه فهم من الجنود
النظاميين والاحتياط لاحظوا العدد عدد
الضباط كبير مقارنه بعدد الجنود يعني يقدر
ب
27% من القتلى هم من الضباط السبب السبب
هو اعتماد الجيش الاسرائيلي على
استراتيجيه جدعون وتهدف لجعل قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقل من حيث العدد البشري ولكن
تكون اكثر كفاءه وتقنيه
وعلما طيب على هذا هل خساره اسرائيل بمقتل
الضابط اكبر من خسارتها بمقتل
الجندي طبعا لماذا يا ابو حميد من السهل
جدا الحصول على جندي في اسرائيل دوره لسته
اشهر الى سنه ثم يحمل السلاح وترميه
بمعركه لكن اعداد الضابط يستغرق ست سنوات
على الاقل من التدريب والمصاريف والدورات
والاختصاص والبعثات الخارجيه ليصبح ضابطا
مؤهلا
وقائدا تعويض خساره الجندي سهله جدا جندي
راح ياتي جندي بدلا منه لكن ليس من السهل
تعويض غياب الضابط سنستعرض بعضا من
تغريداتكم على ارتفاع عدد القتلى من
الضباط الاسرائيليين ابو عبد الرحمن قال
لك ابو عبد الرحمن مزيد من الضباط والجنود
القتلى بسبب مغامرا نتنياهو اسرائيل تخسر
عالميا انسانيا وقانونيا وتكسب قتلى
مواطنين عزا لا سلاح لهم وقريبا ستسقط مدن
وتتحرر من حكم الكيان علي القيسي قال لن
يستطيعوا الصمود اطول من هذا الوقت بسبب
الغضب الشعبي وسينقل السحر على الساحر
قريبا وسترون ذلك راي العين علي قال
السؤال الحقيقي لماذا هذا الاصرار من قبل
اسرائيل على استمرار الحرب بالرغم من
فقدانهم لفلذات اكبادهم وهم يعانون فعلا
وخسائر كبيره ما الثمن الحقيقي لاسرائيل
هل سيبقى اهالي جنودهم صامتين على افعال
نتنياهو الاجراميه يارا قالت دائما نسمع
عن المجازر الاسرائيليه بحق الفلسطينيين
لكن اعترافاتهم بخسائر وقتلاهم تعني انهم
موجوع وان الخسائر اضعاف الارقام المعلن
عنها وهذا يعني الهزيمه لهم والنصر لاهل
غزه يبلغ عدد الجنود النظاميين
الاسرائيليين في الجيش والبحريه والقوات
الشبه العسكريه
169 1500 يضاف اليهم
465000 من الاحتياط الخدمه العسكريه في
اسرائيل الزاميا لمن يبلغ 18 عاما 36 شهرا
للرجال وتخدم النساء ل 24 شهرا